it doesn't matter what kind of
university student you are or what
you're going to study if you're going to
university in 2019 or even early 2020
chances are you're going to need a brand
new laptop right now what's going on
guys my name is David Tom Mitch and
welcome back to the channel today we're
talking about the top five laptops that
you as a university student or a college
student if you're watching this in
America might need to know about so as
you can see behind me I've already done
my hard yards University I've recently
completed my master's in architecture so
I know what it's like to need a very
good very powerful laptop on the go at
all times now I want to preference this
video by saying if you are an
architecture student you're going to
probably need a desktop that's pretty
powerful to get you through those hard
yards not just a laptop but if you're
studying any other discipline that
doesn't require very high intensive 3d
graphics rendering programs then you're
going to be a hundred percent fine with
just a good laptop so I personally
believe when you're purchasing a laptop
for university you want a laptop that's
gonna last you the full duration of your
degree which is more than likely gonna
be at least four years you don't want to
be swapping and changing laptops every
couple of years unfortunately I did have
a lot of problems with my laptop and
University so I went through about eight
different laptops in the space of three
years now that was a huge burden and
something I will talk about in another
video but today we're gonna talk about
the five best laptops on the market
right now that you might be interested
in purchasing in 2019 so at number five
we have the Dell XPS 13 inch laptop the
reason I've put it at the lowest end of
my list today is for the simple fact the
Dell computers are built well personally
speaking a little bit cheap so you don't
get that premium quality feel that you
get with other laptops so I'm not going
to talk about all the specs I'm gonna
list them down beside me here so you
guys can read them off the screen
because nobody's gonna remember
everything I say but you won't get a
chance to look at that over the next 30
seconds when we're talking about a
laptop for university students there are
only really a couple main things there
important for me those major components
are battery life size and also weight
when you're carrying around your laptop
around university campuses all day you
don't want to be carrying a very heavy
laptop all day everyday and straining
your back you don't want to be carrying
around your charger and having it to
plug it in in every single class you go
to and you also don't want a giant
laptop to be really flimsy and racketing
and you know one of those gaming laptops
or studio laptop that's incredibly
powerful but it isn't really needed in a
university setting so with the Dell XPS
13 inch you get the idea of screen size
which is a 13 inch laptop in a very
small compact shell starting at the base
model it only weighs one point to three
kilograms which is a very light package
and it means when you pop it in your bag
you're barely going to feel it one of
the best things about the Dell XPS
besides from the weight is the fact that
it has a 21-hour
advertised battery life now this is an
advertised battery life we know that no
laptop in the world is going to last 21
hours when you're using it the way you
do in a real life setting the XPS got
about 12 and a half hours of battery
life which means if you're a university
student going to every single lecture
going to all your tutorials well most of
my days weren't longer than 12 hours in
a classroom so it was pretty easy to get
through the whole day without having to
charge your laptop which is a great
bonus coming in at number four is the
huawei mate book X pro now this is a
cool computer because it comes in from
Huawei it doesn't come from your
Microsoft Apple your Dell your computer
brands like that they're a niche company
that's dominated the market in
smartphones and now they're pushing into
the market with some really cool laptop
ideas given yes it looks nearly
identical to a macbook pro but hey
that's probably a pretty good win for
some people but for 1900 Australian
dollars you're going to get a pretty
good deal so it comes in with a thirteen
point nine inch display which is
completely touchscreen as well I've got
a touchscreen laptop I don't use it that
much but it is a good feature to have
every now and again you're also going to
get a twelve and a half hour
advertise battery life which actually
comes in at a 10-hour real-world battery
test ten hours is still phenomenal for
any University student taking notes
working on Excel or anything of the
sorts if again you are working with
high-end intensive graphics programs
that is going to drain your battery like
crazy and you're probably going to get
half of these real-world battery
estimates that I'm giving you today so
that's something to keep in mind if for
example you are doing something like I
did at university and studying
architecture number three is the soos
Zen book Pro joy now if you haven't
heard about this computer it's because
it's expensive
and when I say expensive I mean five
thousand plus dollars expensive but
there is a reason for that the Zen Book
Pro comes in with some really cool
features first of all you have a unique
dual screen display so you're able to
maximize your productivity and have
additional apps down the bottom and use
this to really get your work done
productively and effectively it also
comes in with some amazing specs an i-9
processor one terabytes of storage
dedicated graphics something that you
usually see in a high-end Tower build
the Zen Book Pro also comes with a 14
inch 4k display and one of the coolest
features for a laptop that I haven't
seen around lately is fast charging 50
percent battery charge in 15 minutes if
you're a university student running out
of the house woken up late forgot to
charge your laptop
ah frantic you can literally get out of
bed plug your laptop in get ready and by
the time you're ready to get out the
door your laptops at 50 percent charged
and you're gonna be able to make it
through your whole day again now the
reason this comes in at number three and
not number one is for the simple fact it
is so expensive not many university
students are going to be able to go out
and afford a five thousand dollar laptop
just for the fact that it's super cool
super productive and it's going to help
you do some interesting things at
university most of you are going to be
sticking around the one thousand two
thousand two and a half thousand dollar
Australian budget which means about a
thousand two thousand American but I had
to put this computer on the list
because well I'm a tech guy this is a
tech channel and it is an awesome
computer just want to take quick mid
video break to thank the sponsor of this
video me my company so if you don't
already know I own a company called wild
watches their arced actually designed
timepieces check out the link below and
use the code OMG yes to save 50% off
your next order coming in at number 2 is
well by no surprise the MacBook Pro the
MacBook Pro has been your cliche
University laptop for decades now and
really it was the number one laptop to
go to for its battery life nobody was
able to compete with Apple's battery
life in the past but everybody else is
pushing closer and closer and some even
further than Apple now in 2019 so when
you have so many choices why would you
still go to an Apple product well like I
said apples dominated the market for the
past 10 plus years which means they've
done some creative marketing they've
really reeled you in to their Apple
ecosystem and you've probably got an
iPhone or an iPad or something from
Apple that really works well together so
if you already have an iPhone my
recommendation is always go with a
macbook because things are just so
simple and so smooth and their ecosystem
really does work well the only downside
to that is well the fact you're trapped
in their ecosystem if you want to get
out and change your phone from an iphone
maybe to a samsung or maybe to a while
way or Google well it's gonna be very
difficult for you to leave that
ecosystem because all of a sudden your
messages aren't going to go to your
phone all your data isn't gonna be
synced properly and it's gonna be a
little bit of a nightmare to get out now
for the computer that you've all been
waiting for
the number one student recommended
laptop in 2019 drumroll please
he's the Microsoft Surface laptop - now
this might be a pretty obvious choice if
you've seen my channel already you know
that I'm a Microsoft lover I love the
matte black finish I love all the
features about it and I love the sleek
design but there's a lot more to it that
makes it a perfect choice for a
university student I've had people
comment on my channel recently saying
that they're going for about 750 US
dollars on sale right now all across
America and in Australia they're going
for about 1400 - 10 % if you are a
student already so you can pick them up
for relatively cheap if you're doing a
university course that requires simple
note-taking online browsing and the
basic things most people do we laptop
well the computer is absolutely perfect
for you and on the other hand if you're
doing a graphics intensive course like I
do at university the top of the range
Microsoft Surface 2 is again perfect for
everything that you need to do it
doesn't blow the budget it doesn't break
the bank and I know for a fact it's
gonna last you a long time so there you
have it guys I haven't bored you with
all the specs and details I've made sure
to just give you the top 5 computers
that I think you're gonna benefit from
if you're going to university in 2019 or
even starting in 2020 these computers
are available right now in the market
and they're gonna be the absolute best
thing that you can invest in for the
next four years a good computer is going
to save you a lot of headache and a lot
of nightmare the last thing you want to
be doing is stressing about an exam or a
final assignment that you've been doing
working really hard for the past six
eight weeks and all of a sudden your
computer crashes your hard drive crashes
and you've lost all that data no way of
getting it back and have to go running
to your tutors saying look I can't
submit potentially failing your
University's assignments that's all from
me guys thank you so much for watching
if you haven't already make sure you
smash that subscribe button
20-19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday